an Arizona man believed to have murdered
six people in an act of revenge is dead
56 year-old Dwight Jones killed himself
yesterday as police closed in
investigators say at least four of his
alleged victims had links to legal
battles with his ex-wife
Mireya Villarreal is in Scottsdale with
new details on the gunman suspected
motive matéo good morning to you good
morning Dwight Jones opened fire on
police officers that were trying to
capture him at this hotel before he
turned the gun on himself his ex-wife
and her new husband a retired police
detective actually alerted authorities
when they recognized that there could be
a connection between her divorce and the
crime scenes
Dwight Jones's ex-wife connie says her
husband was emotionally disturbed in
rambling audio messages to his son Jones
accused his ex-wife of conspiring
against him along with well-known
forensic psychiatrist dr. Stephen Pitts
yes
dr. Pitts give the exam but the garbage
he made up couldn't get me committed to
a mental ward permanent license on it
police say Pitts was Jones's first
victim had evaluated Jones and testified
against him during the divorce Jones's
next victims Valerie Sharpe and Laura
Anderson were paralegals at the law firm
of his ex-wife's divorce attorney
he also killed Marsha Levine who worked
in an office once used by a counselor
who evaluated Jones's son the final two
suspected victims were 7 year old Mary
Simmons and 72 year old Brian Thomas
Scottsdale Assistant Police Chief rich
Slaven mr. Jones was visiting them in an
effort to right some wrongs
investigators say ballistics DNA and
surveillance video evidence connect
Jones to at least three crime scenes
been hoster is a Scottsdale police
sergeant does this mean the case is
closed right now we're still following
up on other leads other associations and
possibly any acquaintances or help the
suspect may have had with another person
police are still treating this as an
active crime scene anybody wanting to go
in or out of the hotel has to be
escorted investigators are continuing to
look through those divorced
and contact anybody that was involved in
the case although right now there's no
indication that there are any more
victims all right Maria thanks